I will show you the reindeer it's pretty
simple you take that tallest ottoman not
that that's a chair you take this you
take the little nose piece lay it
carefully there and then this little
foot stool becomes antlers hello time to
go be a rain ah time to go be
a time time to go be a
reindeer also this can be a bed you can
use the little reindeer nose as a pillow
when both of these chairs come together
boom it can be a high chair for playing
with a little baby doll oh yeah you know
what you can take uh you can take this
put in those two little kid seats and
make a train Carriage you can also build
a train and I've um I've made a little
reception desks by reception desk hello
hello yes you've called you've called
The Block
Company anyway I have a lot of fun with
it in
fact I have a lot of fun with it